the idea of socialism has become very
popular among young people
and the reason that it's become popular
among young people is because they've
been told that it is moral not that it
works not that it's great but that it's
moral it's fair and we don't like things
that are fair we're in a room and
somebody has more money and somebody has
less money wouldn't it be more fair if
we just pulled the money and then we
split it up evenly among the
participants you know just like the
cookies in kindergarten except of course
that's not the way the world works
and that's not actually moral because in
a free country wealth and the capacity
to gain it is largely contingent on the
decisions that you make it doesn't just
fall upon you most wealth in the United
States is not inherited most well from
the United States is created over the
course of lifetimes by people who engage
in economic activity and commerce
capitalism is good because capitalism is
freedom
socialism is bad because socialism is
tyranny not it's an aspect of tyranny
socialism itself is tyranny the
statement of socialism is that your
labor is owed to the society the notion
of socialism is that you do not own your
own freedom you do not own your own time
you do not own your own labor you do not
own your own work use your not on the
products of your own work the basic
notion of capitalism is you own all of
those things and now you have to engage
in free exchange with someone else who
does not owe you anything
if you want to thrive if you want to
succeed you are going to have to make
something somebody else wants people
think capitalism is selfishness
now socialism is selfishness the notion
that I have to somehow supply you the
money so you can sit in your basement
and paint with watercolors socialism the
idea that I'm supposed to fulfill all
your dreams by paying you for something
I don't want and have no need for